well the thing I've been really
interested in
in my research
- ISM Nazism and the way in which in the
in the human sciences the history of the
human sciences these phenomena came to
be understood and so I started to
excavate really the history of that
endeavor to understand something that
seemed to many people so puzzling which
is why after the first world war there
was this enormous attraction for fascist
leaders of course there was another set
of questions to do with communism and
and sometimes those questions converged
later on in the idea of totalitarianism
which brought together thinking about
Stalinism and and fascism but my
research was really focused on on
fascism and Nazism and particularly the
role of psychoanalysis the role that
Sigmund Freud's theories and the
practice of psychoanalysis came to play
but during the interwar period the 20s
and the 30s and then particularly in the
Second World War the way in which models
of the mind Freud's model of the mind
was deployed by the Allies in trying to
get a deeper understanding of the
attractions of fascism and the more
famous kind of landmarks of that
literature were produced later after the
Second World War
books like Adorno Adorno's the
authoritarian personality and some of
his studies of fascist propaganda and
generally the Frankfurt School work but
what I realized was there was a much
kind of bigger hinterland of Studies on
both sides of the Atlantic that focused
really on that set of problems and it's
a literature that mostly isn't read now
that if it's looked at by historians
it's usually just in a footnote to say
that it was simplistic or bad psycho
biography or psycho history but I think
what I was interested in doing was
historicizing it so showing why it
emerged where it emerged and where it
led and that's really what I I did in
that that project particularly looking
at there were two different stories in a
way I got very absorbed in one was the
story of what happened in
when Rudolf Hess who was the deputy
Fuhrer of the Nazi Party became a
prisoner of state after this bizarre
flight when West came to Inc - to
Scotland on a plane with a kind of
one-man peace mission and then he became
a prisoner and he became the pretty the
patient of various army doctors because
of his his symptoms they started to
study him and to get interested in his
psychopathology and that led to a series
of studies and investigations both in
Britain and then at the Nuremberg trial
of Hesse as an individual and his
psychopathology and on the other side of
the Atlantic at the same time the
American Secret Service's commissioned
some analysts to psychoanalysts to study
Hitler and these were produced as
intelligence reports in in Washington
and I was trying to compare and contrast
these endeavors and a way to situate
them in a bigger thing which was came
from the interwar period which was not
about individuals but about the so
called masses and the most perhaps the
most famous landmark of that literature
would be Vilhelm rice book the mass
psychology of fascism which was in in
1933 the pursuit of the Nazi mind yes I
thought of in pursuit but I changed it
because actually it's not me in pursuit
it's really a book although I'm a
psychoanalyst and a historian I thought
of this book primarily as a history of
the endeavor that was made to pursue
this and to sort of in a way give the
context and to show the diversity of
what was done well I think first of all
I'm skeptical about the idea that there
is such a thing as advert Nazi mind
because clearly there would be a
plurality of states of mind that led to
that attracted people towards fascism so
I think the Nazi mind in a way needs to
be in quotations but it was a concept
that became quite elaborated in the
earlier parts of the century that there
was something essential about the mind
and about fascism that came together and
I think the language of psychoanalysis
did resonate very much in that period in
trying to understand I mean of course
there was a diversity of reasons why
people were drawn to more Cellini Hitler
and other fascist leaders but there was
some sort of sense that the the terrain
that Freud and his followers like
Melanie Klein were investigating that
was relevant to thinking about that the
so-called Nazi mind and people were I
think very puzzled during the you know
the period of the rise of fascism really
to understand this phenomenon of what
was it that seemed in a way so
counterintuitive why people would go for
this this political ideology that was so
extreme so phobic so paranoid in its
structures and that was gradually a
recognition that standard forms of
political theory to explain fascism
didn't seem to quite do it didn't seemed
quite adequate that there was something
else going on a kind of enjoyment of
fascism that you see obviously most in
dramatic ways of things like the
Nuremberg rallies in the 30s but a kind
of identification and excitement and
euphoria in in those sorts of festivals
and spectacles of fascism that demanded
some kind of explanation and why it was
that people were drawn to the to this
kind of extremist philosophy and it was
in that kind of space of puzzlement
about what was going on between the
leader and the led both in the minds of
the of the elite and the entourage
around Hitler and in Hitler himself and
then in the rapport between Hitler and
the and the the larger electorate that
led to a new kind of space for
exploration in the human sciences I
think both psychoanalysis was brought to
bear and also cultural anthropology
other forms of knowledge sociology
history and there was an attempt to in a
where multi
Lenora attempt to bring all of these
these forms of knowledge together to try
to understand what was going on an above
all to learn lessons about how you could
avoid a relapse into new forms of
fascism after 1945 so and when my
research project was both looking at the
the lead-up to the war and the war and
then at the aftermath of the war and the
the attempts that were made in America
in Britain in Paris at UNESCO for
example which was set up as one of the
kind of outcrops of the war through the
UN and then UNESCO but where they they
tried to bring people in who would think
about this in with a concern of their
anxiety how did you avoid a return to
new forms of fascism and I thought those
endeavors were worth recovering and
exploring again because they've also
seem very relevant to us it's not just a
history that's dared or passed it's a
history that in a way is relevant to
contemporary thinking well of course one
of the things that's very notable about
psychoanalysis is it's very much under
attack it's there are other forms both
of therapy that compete with it and many
people are very skeptical about it now
in a way that's been true throughout the
history of psychoanalysis there's always
been a history of controversy
surrounding its efficacy as a clinical
procedure and its theory of the mind and
its method of investigation so I think
that's just part of the history of
psychoanalysis but I think that it does
continue to have relevance as a kind of
resource we have a problematic resource
but nonetheless a very rich resource
both for thinking about mental processes
and it provides a very rich vocabulary
for thinking about the mind I think in a
way it's the most sophisticated account
we have of the inner world you know but
it also does have relevance to thinking
about social cultural political
questions although one needs a big
caveat
with that which is that it can't replace
other forms of knowledge and perhaps
where psychoanalysis was at its worst as
a kind of applied discipline was when it
at times in the 20th century did seek to
replace or to sort of provide a key a
kind of explanatory key to everything as
though it could replace sociology or
anthropology or economics or history and
I think it can't do that and that one
needs to be cautious because minds are
not the same as groups and groups aren't
the same as States all of these levels
of X you know of existence require
different kinds of investigation but I
think nonetheless that psychoanalysis
has something of relevance to offer
because in a way there's a role of
fantasy that is not just in the mind of
individual people but that also
resonates in the life of groups and also
in in culture and ideology that there
can be powerful fantasies mobilized that
psychoanalysis has been quite good at
exploring and contributing to our
understanding of